[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
turn the floor over to eric hoffer who's
going to introduce
today's speaker thanks scott um so i
will briefly introduce
justin uh who's going to be talking
today about failure to disrupt
his new book um on uh educational
technology and its
failure to disrupt educational practices
um justin is a professor here and
compared to media studies and writing
um before that he was a researcher and
lecturer here at mit so he's been
associated with the community for
for many years um doing he taught my my
education courses previously
uh and uh and uh ran our um our
partnership with the woodrow wilson
academy for a number of years
um justin's been doing uh work that i
think i would describe as sort of
healthy skepticism about educational
technologies um
for i think most of his career including
his
his doctoral work and a lot of his work
more recently um
uh you know it's it's sort of taking
this lens on educational technology
that's both sort of hopeful
and and critical in terms of looking at
the ways that it ultimately
um influences um the practices of
educators as well as the lives of the
many students involved in the
educational systems justin runs our
teaching systems lab here which
looks at a lot of issues in professional
development of teachers
use implementation of educational
technologies equity in education
and innovative practices for uh for
training both current and next
generations
of teachers um so with that
i i will hand it over to justin um and
um thanks for for uh coming to
colloquium today justin
thanks eric um we have
some great instructors writing
instructors
who help us teach the media studies
classes to undergraduates at mit
and they try to help media studies
undergraduates
think about what argumentation in media
studies looks like
and one of the ways they describe it is
to say that there
are producers of media and
audiences of media and they sort of
interact
in some way through media in some kind
of broader social context
and everything can get much more complex
than that
the producers can become consumers the
consumers producers all that kind of
stuff but there but there's a kind of
fundamental structure to a lot of common
arguments
um and i would say a lot of my work
is interested in that model as well um
that there are people who take and
facilitate
media as educators and there are people
who consume
that media as learners and sometimes
they pass it back and forth
in some kind of broader context you know
the the thing which
distinguishes me as a learning scientist
from other media studies scholars
is i tend to be keenly interested in
how does that interaction change human
development
um how does the learner develop new
capacities how are they able to do
different kinds of things than they were
before on the basis of that interaction
and i'm hoping that one of the things
that can come out of this conversation
is is i'll present to you some of the
ways that i see the field of education
technology as a learning scientist and i
hope that folks will
will ask questions from a media studies
perspective and
and make you know for the graduate
students make connections to the
readings and other kinds of things
you're working on
faculty the the the research and other
practices that you see or germaine
and we'll see if we can make some some
connections that way
um so one
place that i start my work is that for
the last
20 years people have made some really
extraordinary claims
about how new media might transform the
education landscape
in 2009 a harvard business school
professor clay christensen
predicted that by 2019 last year half
of all secondary school courses in the
united states would be online or blended
that they would cost a third as much to
provide and they would produce better
learning outcomes
in 2012 when massive open online courses
exploded in higher education edx and
corsair and udacity
um sebastian through the founder of
udacity said in 50 years there's only 10
institutions of higher education left in
the world
they're going to be you know a
concentrated set of mega universities
providing the world's best learning
content
all around the world and udacity might
be one of them
sal khan in a 2011 ted talk said let's
use video to reinvent
education let's have individual students
sit down in front of computers
let's have a personalized learning
pathway around mathematics for them
that's sort of optimized for their
individual learning rate and we'll still
have
students and teachers and things like
that but they'll mostly get together
like to do interesting projects
and to you know reflect on what they're
learning and build community but the
sort of heart of
skills development will happen through
these machines
um and then 2013 surgametra
won the ted prize for his proposal that
we didn't even need schools or
educational institutions
anymore that we could simply give kids
laptops and broadband connection
and without any institutional support
they could learn
anything by themselves
and then earlier this year the world was
blighted
by a global pandemic and 1.6 billion
learners
were sent home and to some extent you
might think that like
this was the moment that education
technology was poised for i mean prior
to the pandemic
the case that education technologists
had to make was that they had a set of
offerings that would be better than the
existing traditional educational system
but they didn't even have to make that
claim anymore
they simply had to claim that they could
offer better learning experiences
than uh you know pandemic hobbled system
in the middle of an emergency pivot to
remote teaching
and i think during the last 20 years
one of the reasons why the arguments of
education technologists for the
transformative potential
of learning media was so powerful is
that we saw
these transformations happen in other
sectors
journalism has been profoundly reshaped
by media government and civic media is
in the midst of a
transformation the word friend
means something different than when i
was growing up dating our relationships
i mean some of our most intimate
experiences
are mediated by technology by social
media in particular
in new ways doesn't it stand to reason
that the same kind of thing should
happen in
education as well like why would
education be a sector
that's different from any other sector
um but i think most of you
know what has happened during the
pandemic which is that you know
education technology did not write in
on uh you know a a a flaming horse to
a winged horse to save us all in fact i
think most people
most families especially of of younger
children
but i think many folks in higher
education and well have have experienced
something ranging from like eh this is
adequate
to um wow this is really a disaster for
us and for our families um
and in fact two of the technology i
think the two most prominent
technologies of the pandemic are two of
the very oldest technologies that we
have
so so i would argue that the two
technologies that have dominated the
pandemic are learning management systems
which are basically platforms that allow
people to pass documents
back and forth with one another the
canvas schoology google classroom
um these were theorized in the 60s and
70s they were commercialized in the
1990s they were made open source in the
2000s
and then the other you know perhaps
dominant technology of the pandemic
has been what in the 1930s when it was
introduced was called video telephony
now goes by the term of video
conferencing
and i think what we saw both in higher
education and in k-12 education
was you know a a a series of collective
acts of conservatism small c
conservatism
the likes of which we will never again
see in our lifetime
faced with dramatically changing
circumstances
you know most of the professor it like
walked away from their lecterns
and sat down in front of their home
office video cameras
and kept teaching you know roughly the
same way that they were teaching
beforehand
despite all the transformations
happening in the world
and despite the promises of people that
technology would
rearrange those relationships even in
normal times
let alone pandemic times so my task
as a writer in this book is to explain
why that is um to explain
why these arguments of transformation
can be so tractable at times can be so
compelling at times
but also the argument is that they
shouldn't be so compelling because
they're
routinely not true and that there are
more productive stances to take
towards the role of technology in
schools
last year uh before the pandemic
sal khan gave an interview to a little
trade magazine
called district administration so i'm
sure millions of people have seen sal
khan's ted talks i promise you that it
was like me
and four other people um who read this
interview
in district administration magazine it
turns out that in the last decade salcon
had not only built khan academy this
library of videos
on instructional topics and an adaptive
tutor and other kinds of tools but he
actually built a
regular in-person school there's a
private school i think it's in silicon
valley area it costs 20 or 25 000
a year to attend and his observation
after working on this project for a long
time was now that i run a school i see
that some of this stuff is not as easy
to accomplish compared to how it sounds
theoretically
um and his new argument
um was that actually a better way it was
it's not going to be the case that khan
academy
um is going to transform relationships
in schools we are not going to have
students who are spending all you know
most of their time developing skills
through these individual pathways
and at the end of their skill
development coming together for rich
intricate project-based learning
instead the model that he's recommending
is to teach
about the way you had been teaching four
days a week and then use khan academy as
practice problems one day a week
and he says that's doable that's
tractable
um and it's also has some benefits for
students math learning
um the thing that struck me in a
powerful way about that argument
um was how incredibly well established
it was so you can go back to the 1990s
here's an article from 1997 published by
ken katinger
at carnegie mellon university where they
had done in the pittsburgh schools
the exact thing they had built a series
of
cognitive tutors adaptive tutors that
responded to
students responses and gave them
progressively easier harder or properly
sequenced
math challenges and they told teachers
to use it
three or four days a week i think they
told them to use it three days a week or
they told them to use it
one to two days a week and teach in a
regular way three or four days a week
and
they ended up for the most part if they
used it using it one day a week
and they found the same kinds of things
that sal khan found 25 years later which
is that
um if you have people teach in a regular
way four days a week and then use
adaptive tutors as practice problems one
day a week
it works a little better than what had
come before
um you know another way to frame this is
that you know khan academy i think has
raised like 150
million dollars in philanthropic support
um over the last
uh eight or nine years and uh you know
what they what they learned from that
investment
you could have discovered with it with a
trip to the library um so
when i contrast sal khan of
2011 with sal khan of 2019
um i see two different kinds of stances
towards education technology at work and
over the last two decades
one of the most powerful stances has
been the charismatic stance and i borrow
this term from
morgan ames who did a really lovely
anthropology
of the one laptop or child program that
was situated from the media lab here at
mit and she wrote a book called the
charisma machine
and talked about charismatic
technologists
people who envision technology as tools
that can
disrupt and transform and rearrange
existing systems
and who imagine futures that are brand
new and different because of new
technologies
um and she contrasts that with actually
sort of what i see
in sao khan in 2019 um with the
tinkering stance
that she draws from a book from from two
historians david tayak and larry cuban
called tinkering towards utopia
and in the tinkering stance the
assumption is not that new technologies
will disrupt and transform
educational systems but rather that
these existing
conservative complex political systems
will domesticate new technologies
they will take new technologies and they
will slot them into particular niches
for particular students particular
contexts particular subjects and that
the future
in many ways can be seen as an extension
of trends from history
that things change uh but they don't
change
disruptively they change incrementally
um
uh uh they they change uh step by step
and in some ways the the book failure to
disrupt
you know is like a love letter to the
tinkerers
or or a passionate plea um for honoring
and respecting the work of tinkerers
and it is to say that that the
charismatic stance leads us to
sort of boom and bust hype cycles around
education technology
in which we misallocate our resources um
and by contrast there are ways
that technology can help improve
existing systems for learning
um but they tend not to be breakthroughs
like a lot of things in human
development they tend to be a few steps
forward and a couple steps back
and kind of maddeningly slowly plotting
um but perhaps ultimately you know
leading to improvements
or potential improvements in human
capacity or at least if we're going to
make investments in education technology
that's the sort of stance to bring to it
so the first half of the book sort of
reviews what i think is one of the most
useful disciplines
for the tinkerer a kind of personal
discipline
which is to start from the assumption
that any new technology
is situated in some kind of history and
if we know something about that history
we can make some pretty good guesses
about how a new technology will operate
um so to illustrate that principle i
look
at a set of technologies that i call
learning at scale
learning environments for many many
learners and few experts to guide them
typically education technology
evangelists have not promoted
calculators as
transformative tools of teaching and
learning because there's not a sense
that calculator
kind of on its own provides a you know a
personalized individualized curriculum
that is scalable
to many millions of people but there are
other technologies we've created in
which ed tech evangelists have made that
promise
and they tend to fall into three
different categories and you can define
those categories by who guides the
sequence of learning activities
so there are learning environments in
which an instructor
selects the the suggested sequence of
activities and those are things like
massive open online courses there
are algorithm guided large scale
learning environments like adaptive
tutors
where a computing algorithm measures
student performance on some dimension
and on the basis of that measure selects
some new
learning activity to suggest for a
student and there are
driven peer guided network learning
communities
you know at mit i use the example of the
scratch programming language and
community
where the learning experience of
scratchers is in profound ways
shaped by the community of peers that
they interact with
on the scratch platform almost all of us
participate in these kinds of networks
in some way if you're interested
in how to do makeup on your face in new
ways or how to style your hair
or how to beat a level in a video game
or how to
do different kinds of handicrafts if
you're watching videos posting pictures
reading reddit threads you're probably
participating in one of those kinds of
networks
each of those three genres
has a history behind it um they
tend to have similar kinds of
pedagogical proclivities
they tend to use similar you know to
borrow the terms of software developers
sort of
similar technology stacks um so the
first
and the other thing is that for most of
them we have a kind of track record
of efficacy behind them um as the
example
of ken katinger's 1997 research and sal
khan's 2019 proclamations point out
you know we human beings have been using
computers to try to teach other human
beings for as long as we've had
computers
this is not a brand new field
this is a 60-year enterprise
conducted with substantial funding by
super bright people at research labs all
over the world
and so if you find a new piece of
education technology i argue
that you can sort of ask this question
who guides the sequence of learning
activities here
and you can see how it sort of slots
into one of these three genres and if
you know something about these
three genres you can make a good guess
about
how some new technology will
shape the future i think i won't spend a
ton of time with this although we can
come back to it
except to say that you know for instance
i think that instructor-guided and
algorithm-guided
genres of learning technology they tend
to be inspired by pedagogies that
emphasize
direct instruction and experts
communicating
information to novices whereby contrast
peer guided learning environments
tend to be interested in pedagogies of
apprenticeship
where you learn not so much from the
received wisdom of experts but through
the process of
trying things interacting with others
sharing your experience
in the in the middle slot here i
indicate some technologies that i think
are
quite common um to these genres so for
instance
most adaptive tutors they really have
two main parts
they have an auto grader and the auto
grader is what allows us to determine
the level of human performance so we can
select some other task
and almost all of them no matter how
fancy they purport to be no matter how
many billions of cells of data
they purport to collect no matter how
fancy you know the algorithms or the
parameterization they claim to have
at their core they almost all use some
variant of a statistical toolkit called
item response theory
an item response theory was developed by
the educational testing services in the
1980s and i will describe it to you now
but i take maybe three pages in the book
to describe it to readers
with the point being that this is not um
intractable this is not impossibly
complex
which is what education technology
evangelists often try to convince us of
like the fundamental building blocks of
this are well known and they're usually
old you know if you see a sort of
edtech roadster coming your way like
lift up the hood
and you will see like oh that's a pretty
old engine or that's a pretty old
chassis or there's some
well-established pieces here and if we
understand
those well-established pieces then we
can make some good guesses about how a
new technology will operate in the
future or we can identify
the pieces of a new technology that are
in fact distinctly new like it's very
unlikely
that the whole thing that we've created
is going to reimagine
you know pedagogies that we've been
working on for
thousands of years in our society but
maybe they have some particularly
interesting tweak and if you can
identify that particularly interesting
tweak
then you can think of that as a place
for study and exploration and other
kinds of things
and i can talk in more detail and do in
the book about you know how
i think uh a math department head should
examine this history of technology when
making a decision about how to implement
a new piece of math software in their
school
how a vice provost for information
technology might do that how a
researcher
might identify what kinds of interesting
problems are out there how a designer
might think about how to approach the
development of new software
um so in the in the second half of the
book
what i try to tackle are uh
is making clicking work um are
what i call four as yet intractable
dilemmas
um four issues that come up time and
again
um across all of these different genres
of technology um problems that
um if people interested in technology
at different levels developers
researchers implementers teachers
students if we thought about these
problems in
in creative ways if we were diligent
about trying to address them
that would be our best chance of sort of
tinkering our way to success
and they and the problems emerge from
three key features of educational
systems
um three key features of these systems
that i think are really central to
understanding
why technology doesn't lead to
disruptive
society shifting change in education in
the way it does in other fields
and the first piece of the education
landscape is that education is just
immensely almost unfathomably complex
um somewhere today there was a teacher
who was a seventh grade earth science
teacher who was starting a new unit on
plate tectonics
and somewhere else there was a
kindergarten teacher who across
a zoom video conference was trying to
explain to students
how to open a new tab in a browser or
how to tie their shoes
and somewhere else there was an advanced
mandarin class uh being taught in a
in a liberal arts college somewhere else
and you know and then somewhere else
there's a two-year degree program where
people are learning how to be radiology
techs
um the you know and it's not just that
those subject areas and those contexts
are different
but what you do the interactions you
have with your students
day to day the the content that you
cover the skills that you address they
are constantly changing
um across the 180 days of a k-12 school
year or the 28 weeks of a
of two semesters of higher education
it's extremely difficult to think about
how technologies could be built
to address all of those kinds of diverse
use cases
and indeed the technologies that we have
are very
uneven they work well in some
circumstances but not
others for some people but not others
in some contexts in some subjects but
not others
and i think that is one of the you know
sort of fundamental misunderstandings
that people often have
of of when they predict sweeping changes
from
education technology they're imagining
there are technologies and i haven't
found the right metaphor here but
they're like bulldozers or they're like
swiss army knives they sort of
clear everything out or they do
everything but our technologies are not
that way
they solve very particular problems
typically
they're like very specific pegs um
and the complexity of education is just
this like manifold huge sweeping
landscape
of lots and lots of different kinds of
holes um and then
our education system especially here in
the united states but certainly in lots
of other places in the world
is shaped by profound inequality
we provision students in their schools
and students in their homes very very
different levels of resources with which
to approach the challenge of education
um and that shapes every part of our
education system and certainly
some of the some of the saddest thinking
and reflecting
to be done about the pandemic is how it
has both revealed
and exacerbated those inequalities
so i'll briefly talk about these four
dilemmas and then maybe i'll
stop for a bit and uh and see what
questions or thoughts that folks have
but here
here are four of the kinds of things
that i think whether you're interested
in network learning environments or
learning games or adaptive tutors or
moocs i think these are problems that
sort of
cut across these different kinds of
approaches to learning at scale
um so one has to do with complexity and
i call it the curse of the familiar
if you build a technology that is
familiar to people
you can get that technology adopted the
most widely
used technology education technology
maybe in american schools
is a tool called quizlet which was
created
by an mit dropout and a former students
of eric's and the terrific guy
and quizlet lets you generate online
flash cards and
when you glance at the operation of the
quizlet website
you will instantaneously understand
what's going on you'll go oh this is a
flash card like i'm alright question on
one side and answer on the other side
i'm going to test myself
i'm going to share the decks with other
people these are flash cards
because it is instantaneously
recognizable it can spread
very very widely but if we sat down a
bunch of experts
in the american education system and
said to ourselves like what are the real
problems
that we face here in education with
inequality
with the challenges of the future of the
labor market what do we really need to
work on here
i think very few experts would come up
with the answer like man we really have
a dearth of flashcards out there in the
schools like we really have to improve
flashcard access for children across the
united states
um the new flashcards are neat
um but they because they don't offer any
kind of substantial change
in the way that teachers and students
interact with one another with the
content
um they are very unlikely to lead to
substantial improvements
they gain a certain number of
inefficiencies and they help students
memorize some things better
but they're they're not sort of
unlocking new pathways of teaching and
learning
by contrast when we do build things that
unlock new pathways to teaching and
learning
users often find them confusing so if we
create
things new technologies that incorporate
alternative pedagogies or create new
routines or relationships between
teachers and students
it's often the case that this confuses
teachers and students
and these things sometimes get
passionately adopted in small niches
but very rarely spreading scale across
systems
in the cases in which we do have some of
our most interesting technologies
sort of get into schools and start to
spread and start to change the way
teaching and learning happen
they tend to do two things um and this
is where in the second half of the book
i try to propose
you know some so not sort of pat
solutions but some
approaches to addressing these
intractable dilemmas
they tend to be able to be used for
familiar ways
initially and then span out into new
kinds of opportunities
so quizlet gets in in a very simple way
with flashcards
but doesn't really take you anywhere
beyond flashcards
i have colleagues who built this
graphing calculator tool called desmos
which in at first glance just does
everything a ti 84 calculator does
on your computer for free but then
beyond that there's a whole set of ways
of using
this graphing software that enables a
whole different kind of
approach to teaching and learning in
mathematics
and so it meets people in a familiar
place and takes them somewhere else
and then the second thing that people do
when they successfully navigate the
curse of the familiar
and this is sort of a theme that cuts
across uh both
the book failure to disrupt um and a lot
of my current critiques of how we're
addressing
online learning during the pandemic um
is that the
the people who are good at taking
technologies and spreading them and
having new pedagogy spread with them
they don't assume that that new ideas
will travel with the technology
they assume that they have to engage
communities of faculty members teachers
and learners
in pedagogical exploration about how to
do new things
um so the you know mit media scratch lab
they built scratch but they are also in
the midst of building this giant
apparatus to teach people all over the
world
what are the pedagogies of computational
creativity
that are associated with scratch because
scratch by itself if you sort of drop it
into schools
um it will be it will be you know
domesticated by those schools
for conventional teaching and learning
but it provides an opportunity
for allowing people to reimagine those
ideas but only
if faculty and students and communities
are supported
in doing that learning and doing that
rethinking you know it's a way of
thinking about
scaling of new ideas not through
technology distribution
but through movement making um through
community building
through the kinds of things that we see
in other forms of social movements
a second challenge i call the edtech
matthew effect um
and matthew effects are commonly
observed across sociology
uh they you know it comes from a line in
the book of matthew which is
paraphrase something like he who has
much much more will be given
and do he who has little more will be
taken away
there is a persistent story in education
technology
that will have the capacity that new
technologies will democratize
education that they will make education
more free more fair more just
my colleague larry cuban who's an
emeritus professor at
stanford has marked how these arguments
go back to the days of radio
he's a great book called teachers and
machines in which
he has a picture of a bunch of young
people sitting around
a radio receiver that's the size of a
small child um you know one of those big
stand-up units and the caption is you
know with radio the underprivileged
school becomes a privileged one
um and you all know that radio did not
um you know squash the inequalities uh
uh
that occur between our schools and
united states um and nor
will other technologies that we develop
on their own
new technologies disproportionately
benefit the affluent
because those people have the financial
and social and technical capital to take
advantage of new
innovations um and it's only through
deliberate efforts at really thinking
about what would it look like to create
technologies
that close gaps rather than spread us
further apart
um through things like do our
technologies
you know can we measure and assess um or
observe
how people from different backgrounds
and life circumstances use technologies
differently
a tragic thing that we're going to
research over the next year
and and learn in different ways is that
white children in american schools and
black children in american schools
are not going to be treated the same way
on zoom
that the behaviors of the you know the
subjectively inappropriate behaviors of
black students
um on zoom calls will be policed in ways
that they are not
for white students and if we don't find
ways of looking at what's happening
during the current pandemic
and looking at it through the lens of
how do people from different backgrounds
and life circumstances
experience technology differently um
then
we will miss the opportunity to to learn
about those things and figure out
how we might be able to address them
a third challenge relates to unevenness
which is the trap of routine assessment
which is that many of our large-scale
learning technologies
depend upon automated assessment and we
have
some domains in which we do really good
automated assessment
in some domains where we don't if you
ask someone
a question with a well-defined right
answer a computational question
a question in a physics system where the
laws of physics
are well defined we can build good
auto graders that evaluate those
responses from learners
one of the fields in which we've built
the the most impressive auto graders is
in the field of computer programming
where computer science professors and
teachers can assign their students
computer programs to write that have to
meet certain engineering challenges
and they can create computer programs
that grade
those assignments and when you can do
that in automatic way you can
build systems where people at their own
pace and time
can participate learning experiences get
some feedback from an automated system
be motivated and inspired by their
progress or be supported by different
kinds of feedback
and then proceed and move forward in
their learning there are lots of domains
we can't
do this very well probably the most
important one is that we really don't
have good tools for evaluating
writing for evaluating people's ability
to reason from evidence
this is a problem because much of what
we teach in a liberal arts education is
how to reason from evidence
perhaps most problematically the things
that we're good at building computers to
assess
tend to be the kinds of things that
computers are already good at they're
highly structured highly routine kinds
of problems
that arguably we don't really need
people to do that much anymore
by contrast the things where humans have
a comparative advantage
over machines in the labor market or
sort of equivalent contact
you know concept in the civic sphere um
are areas in which we don't have very
good automated assessment so you know
the problem here is that we're
we're really good at creating assessment
systems for things that we don't need
people to do anymore
um and this is not because there aren't
smart people who are working
on this problem um decades of work by
very very smart people in technology
companies and universities
have thrown all kinds of resources at
this challenge
and instead of having you know some kind
of moore's law
like exponential growth and improvement
we've seen very very little progress
here in decades
and i think that should give us some
humility and caution
about about our predictions for the
future for lots of education technology
evangelists
um it will make a prediction and then
when it doesn't come true they'll say ah
just we just need a little longer
um thomas edison in 1913 said that by
in 10 years uh all uh textbooks would be
replaced
by the films that he was producing um
and then in 1923 he gave uh
i think it was in front of the fcc um
and he made a similar argument except ah
he said well actually
it's going to take 20 years but it'll
happen that all the textbooks will be
replaced by
film strips and we still have not
replaced um you know 100 years later
all of the all of the textbooks with
video materials because it turns out
that
print is a pretty good media for
learning in a lot of different ways
then the last challenge that i map out
is that
if you're someone who's excited about
building and improving
software platforms you're probably very
interested
in the large amounts of data that these
systems can collect
and then the ability to rapidly run
experiments
that let you test how changes the
software platform
affect people's experiences
you know are all kinds of regulatory
issues with this and there's all kind
you know sort of cultural policy issues
there's some sense in society that if i
go to amazon
to buy a book that they should be able
to collect some data about my experience
there
and that you know if i find out that
sometimes they're doing
you know randomized controlled trials to
see if i'm more likely to buy a book
with a blue button
or a red buy button that you know at
least i as an individual
entered into that learning experience
you know into
that software experience um somewhat of
my own free will
and volition not entirely um but but as
wicked as the problem is
in retail it's much much worse in
education
um because you know right now all across
the world
young people are both compelled to go to
school
and they are compelled to use the
software platforms
that are assigned by their teachers and
school systems
and so there are all kinds of reasons to
be very seriously concerned
both about the immediate risks of
surveillance
in these systems but also about the
long-term kind of educational social
risks of
normalizing and socializing young kids
to live in surveillance cultures
there are lots of circumstances in the
social sciences where we think
experiments are like generally good
we tend to not intuitively think of
experimenting on young
children learning as a thing which is
good
i think i think there are ways to do
these things uh
responsibly but i also think that there
are
real serious concerns that are that are
embedded in these practices
and if we want to see the same kind of
improvements in learning technologies
that we've seen in other kinds of retail
software platforms
we're going to have to resolve and
negotiate some of these kinds of
challenges
so that's what the the second half of
the book tries to address it tries to
chart out you know the first half is
really more of a history the second half
is more of a
of an engineering text of trying to say
here are four
common problems that we run into all the
time and here are some approaches that i
think
might be able to solve them um you know
and as i've
reflected on you know what the lessons
of this you know
in the prologue i mentioned that the the
final copy edits of the book were done
like march
23rd um the the book was written
right at the end of one era and just at
the beginning
of this new one and a lot of what i've
done over the last eight months
is both try to be helpful but also try
to reflect on um
what do we learn from the pandemic
that's that's that's salient from
history and i think
two important lessons at least come
through
one constant mistake that education
technologists make
is to describe technology as sweeping to
describe it as something that can sort
of
uh sweep away existing systems and usher
in new ones
and instead for a variety of reasons our
education systems
are are conservative institutions
because they're extraordinarily complex
and they're managing
all these different competing interests
and as a result new technologies tend to
be domesticated we tend to slot them
into existing functions
which is why we perhaps shouldn't be
surprised that all the faculty walked
away from their lecterns
and went to their home webcams and you
can decry
that as you know a sort of pitiful
conservatism in a system
or you can say wow um this system is so
well honed um to meet its competing
interests
that it's actually kind of found a local
maximum a local
optimization of all the different
resources and competing constraints
um and then the the second problem that
i think technologists often make
which is quite salient to our moment now
is that
technologists often describe education
technology as a switch that you can flip
on and on
you sort of buy it and install it and
then it works and that's not at all how
education
technology works education technologies
are only as useful
as their communities of users
are well supported and strong they are
powerful tools for rethinking learning
for
imagining iterative and continuous
improvements to learning
but there's very very few things that
we've created that just kind of
instantly and meaningful ways benefit
learning rather
they become useful and we're seeing now
all over the world
millions of faculty members engaged in
the process of asking themselves
okay i'm forced to use this new
technology now um
what are what am i doing what are my
colleagues in my discipline or my
subject or my school doing
and how do i have to rethink my practice
or rethink my approach
to have a more powerful more effective
more connecting more exp inspiring
experiences
from learning so those those two things
of technology is particular and and
domesticated by systems rather than
sweeping
um and the strengths of technology not
being its instantaneous
effects but by its ability to be
absorbed
by uh by community of learners are
perhaps the two things that i'll
leave you with before uh before taking
some questions
uh i just want to invite everybody um
if you're uh if you're currently a
panelist um
i think it's fine to just unmute
yourself and call out
at this moment um just
be mindful of someone that speaks up
before you um
if you are a guest feel free to put a
question in the q a
um so
um i'm going to start with a question
then because no one else is
calling out um i know
in the beginning of my work in
educational technology and i realized it
was a fallacy but i had this
sort of um
we i guess it was a wish that if a
technology
of a in my case game um
sort of made that it could somehow
make people who used it aware of whole
different
models of pedagogy and when in fact
what we cross learn is that teachers
tend to even if they're using something
as radical for them as a game
they're going to tend to fall back on
the same pedagogies they've always used
are there exceptions that or is that as
yeah as eric yes mentioned the trojan
mouse that was
that was the term that he always used um
are there no is there no evidence of
that is there some evidence of that of
uh
of the technology actually shifting the
thinking of the people who adopt it
i mean my view is is that there's not
good evidence of the technology
here maybe three things there's not good
evidence of the technology in and of
itself shifting people's views
um a second thing that they're um
that there there is good evidence of is
that technology
has an ability to catalyze
thinking about those kinds of issues
so it's possible to um
you know you you could you can go into
uh
a group of faculty members and say the
future is going to be really different
the world is changing our learners have
a whole set of new experiences and as a
result we think you should rethink your
relationships your curriculum your
pedagogy all those kinds of things
um and um many faculty respond with like
no thank you we're doing fine
and then you bring a learning game into
that same community experience
you know or some other form of
technology and it you know operates as
kind of like a symbol of the future to
be able to say oh
like we could do things really
differently here um
we could uh you know this gives us new
opportunities and new affordances new
ways to rethink things
and so i think it can catalyze those
conversations
and then another thing that we know is
if people do move
from more familiar practices to new
practices it's a developmental process
um you know judith sandholz did this
project in the 1980s
um called the apple classrooms of
tomorrow where she
um with a team of folks you know got
some k12 classrooms and got a bunch of
apple two plus computers
and um had wired networked with you know
these for some of the first networked
um computing environments and they had
robots and printers and things like that
and she described teachers going along a
developmental trajectory
from using things in more familiar ways
to using things in slightly novel ways
to doing
really imaginative work faculty members
travel along that continuum at different
rates
um to a limited extent they start in
different places but really a lot of
them start
at that first spot like what is the mo
you know how do i use this to extend
existing practices
um and then i can think about uh
new and different and interesting kinds
of things so
uh um i you know and that's
and that's why i think it's so important
to pair
the idea of technology integration
with the idea of community learning at
the same time like can games do that
sure
but not when games fall from the sky
it's more likely to happen
when games arrive with a community of
people who are interested in teaching
and sharing these ideas i mean mitch
resnick has a great line that he
had with the release of scratch 3.0
which was something like you know we're
gratified at how widely scratches spread
in schools
and we've been somewhat surprised at how
challenging it's been
um not to spread the technology of
scratch but to
spread the ideas and the pedagogy behind
scratch and you know one of the things i
admire about that group
is that you know rather than saying like
oops disruption didn't work like let's
go try something else
they're like okay great you know let's
work in a really diligent devoted way
on that human development problem as
well
i have uh again uh people
if you're feel free to talk but i've got
some questions in the q a
um someone said i very much enjoyed
logic and
what do you see regarding the future of
this platform
so i i have a chapter about moocs
instructor guided learning and i
and i claim that they had three big bets
um that they would provide
new pathways for different kinds of
people into higher education that they
would
unbundle and rearrange higher education
systems
um and that they would usher in
a new era of data-driven learning
science
and i think none of those things
basically has happened um
i was one of the people who's working
pretty hard on trying to usher in
a new era of data-driven learning
science
and i don't think that we've been
particularly successful and i think we
may make incremental progress but i
don't see like breakthroughs on the
horizon
um what ended up happening with moocs is
that they were
domesticated into the existing higher
education system for the most part
um many i have a whole section that you
know many mooc providers
have started describing themselves as
online program managers
these are people who largely create um
professional master's degrees in a set
of topics that are amenable to being
taught online
um and they have a familiar business
model
of paying upfront for the costs of
course and curriculum development
and then taking an ongoing fraction of
student tuition revenue after that there
some respects involve outsourcing the
core competencies of universities
which is which generally across
businesses thought of as a bad idea
um you you outsource your janitorial
services you outsource your accounting
you outsource things that are peripheral
to the core operations
you don't outsource teaching and
learning um you know i think moocs are
just a terrific illustration of the
incredible power of education systems to
domesticate to incorporate new ideas
and there are a few places where i think
there's some really neat things
happening
you know the georgia tech has an online
masters of computer science
taught through a series of moocs which
is like 7 000 people at any given time
enrolled in it you know it'll it'll
probably end up graduating on an annual
basis
16 of the computer science master's
degrees
but it was not a harbinger of a whole
new set of higher education
there was like one particular subject
area at one particular university which
has captured a modestly large niche
and they'll probably be some other you
know accounting degrees or data science
degrees that like kind of work the same
way probably not as well
um and uh um
and that you know and and it's and it's
better to understand
you know um i think i think the saddest
part of the mooc story is that there are
lots of universities
that took limited funding and invested
enormous resources
and saw very few benefits of them
because they
weren't you know one of the lucky few
early adopters or people who got things
just right or or
institutions at other places that have
sort of bottomless funds for these kinds
of things
and i still you know i make moocs we
launched one uh last week
called sorting truth from fiction about
civic online reasoning they're really
good at teaching
already educated already affluent people
um some of the already educated
already affluent-ish people in society
are teachers
and teachers lead busy complex lives and
moocs are a great way to reach lots of
them
at relatively low marginal cost but
that's
again sort of slotting into a particular
niche into systems
in which we're hoping to incrementally
over time improve our practice at them
rather than arguing that you know we're
on the cusp of a transformation in
teacher education
and i see we have a question from ambar
um
hi justin uh thank you i was wondering
uh a question about related to students
and what about advice do you have for
students
like in the current educational climate
uh to make the most out of this
experience
[Music]
what advice do i have for students i
really i had a whole set of slides that
i was sort of clicking through i was
talking i just realized that i forgot to
put them up but i also think that
sometimes it's nice just to hear people
chatting but i at least wanted to have a
link to the
book up there um yeah my advice for
students is first of all
i think students at all age levels and
around the world
should celebrate all of the resilience
that they've shown
and all of the unconventional learning
that they're doing during this period
so i think the most common narrative
around
learners right now is like some kind of
deficit framing around learning loss
like oh man these kids are just not
learning all the stuff that they're
supposed to learn in the curriculum
they're going to fall behind and there
are very serious issues of that they're
very serious inequality issues of that
but that's not all that happened i think
there are lots of
people around the world who have spent
this time as part-time or full-time
learners who've learned all kinds of
awesome stuff
about negotiating technology as learners
about um
showing more independence and more
self-directed learning
and so i think you know i'm a big fan of
sort of asset approaches to thinking
about these things
there there are not there's not a set of
good sort of simple advice along the
line of study tips
that make people better online learners
if there's one basic one it would be
something like um
people often do this is true for
everything but particularly online
people do a better job learning things
they really care about and they're
interested in
than people than what they were this or
what you're being forced to take um
you know if you were a freshman at mit
right now
um i would encourage you to
save some of your gir some of your
required courses that you're not that
excited about for when you come back
and do the things that you're just most
intuitively interested in now
um because it's because motivation is
really essential part
of uh of learning and then a piece you
know that i say
mostly to faculty but i think applies to
students too is
i hope we approach this period of
pandemic learning as something that
we're all in together
i'd really try to encourage faculty to
say like how can you partner with
students
in designing your response to this
because there's exactly one group of
americans one group of people around the
world that have
been learners during a pandemic and it's
the students who are in our classrooms
this spring
and this fall and they know a lot that
we don't know
about what good teaching and learning in
a pandemic looks
like and we should really listen to them
so maybe that's a plea for you all the
students to
to try to share that with your faculty
and and to be in those partnerships with
students
and we do have some questions um i'm
going to take them in the order they
showed up will well
yes thank you um i was wondering if uh
the the kind of like shifting views
about time scale that we've been
considering with the pandemic have like
changed people's stances from
either like a charismatic stance towards
like interventions or just like a
band-aid kind of
we're just going to deal with it for a
couple months and then we'll go back to
normal to more of like a tinkering
stance of
you know maybe we're going to be in this
situation for a year or more
so we can think about like slower kinds
of experiments and other
sort of solutions that might take a
longer time to figure out
um if that's something that you've
noticed and if so like
what does that look like if it's coming
from educators or technologists
well i'm always amazed at the
technologists like you know there's some
people who just really
devoted to the charismatic stance and
like nothing will stop them
um so there's a guy michael moe who
helps run
um asu arizona state university's
partnership with gsv
and he had this they ran a series of
events called like the dawn of online
learning
um it's like didn't we have the dawn 10
years ago or 20 years ago like
like oh you know maybe you don't think
dawn is like a watershed moment in
history dawn is just a thing that
happens every day
early in the morning that we all kind of
sleep through um
sort of these repeated cyclical pieces
so the charismatics are still out there
but the thing which is like
really taking the wind out of
charismatic sails i think
is that like this should have been their
moment
and i just see like no
hue and cry for the kinds of large-scale
learning technologies
to an extent that has even surprised me
i mean at the beginning of pandemic i
told a lot of my colleagues at mit
the odds that you can in the midst of a
pandemic like go home and sort of whip
together a decent
online learning experience for your
students is pretty low um
and you've built a bunch of stuff
already on open courseware and on mitx
like just point people to that and kind
of help them out
um you know i actually thought it would
have been more a moment for
moocs and some other kinds of things um
but it turns out that at mit and as far
as i can tell in lots of other places
around the world as well
it's not what people wanted um there has
been no nowhere that i can text some
groundswell of students saying like
you know my introductory microeconomics
professor is doing a crappy job
teaching us um intro micro online
and i just want to be able to take a
mooc and learn it myself um
instead i think what we overwhelmingly
see is like people really do
want the connection to their individual
professor
who's like doing lousy job managing kids
in the background
and putting together their first online
course um
because i think that human connection is
enormously important so i mean you know
the whole purpose of the book is to try
to inoculate
educators from future hype cycles to try
to convince you know the next time
someone comes around and says like oh
it's going to be
ar or vr it's going to be you know data
science artificial intelligence is going
to change
everything is to say well like that's
that's
very unlikely to happen um and there
and they're going to be a lot of places
that don't spend resources wisely
chasing those kinds of pursuits um so so
i mean one of my answers to your
question is like of course the tinkers
are going to win now
um but that but you should be cautious
because that's who i'm rooting for
anyway
thank you mike you want to go
yeah sure uh apologies justin this is a
little too
heavy of a question but it's something
i'm really curious about throughout your
here
um so i maybe maybe like a charitable
way
to assess why the charismatic technology
and parasite technologists are so
successful
is because they are appealing to these
values which are like pretty noble right
democratizing and like fixing inequities
and like i think what that morgan games
book is so great at showing and what
your presentation's gonna be showing is
like you know technologies of technology
you know if you want to fix that stuff
you have to fix inequity
and you have to fix uh democracy and all
that type of stuff
and this is a moment where we're kind of
having this reckoning of like okay there
are a lot of issues that we have with
our system set up
a lot of issues what we expect
technology to do and there are a lot of
issues with the people who made a lot of
money from technology so i guess the
question is you know in a system
that has previously assigned the value
of certain technologies
and education trends to monetary value
what they can get from investors and
non-profits and all of that
um what might creating a new set of
values you're going to a more
fundamental set of values
while dealing with this technological
space look like right like
maybe we can't fix we can't democratize
technology with
zoom or with khan academy but maybe we
still need to democratize maybe we have
technology
what might that look like i mean i i
think the stance that
the skeptics that i find most compelling
take
um is you know that
the project of education is like fundam
is a fundamental part of civil society
it should be fundamentally thought of as
a public good
um it should be you know sort of
fundamentally democratic
and therefore you know accruing enormous
power
to technology firms to be able to
influence these environments
no matter how well intentioned they are
no matter
how useful their products are it's the
wrong
people doing it um we you know um
i you know i i think i think it matters
a lot
you know that zoom is a piece of
consumer
software sold in a publicly traded firm
and scratch was developed in uh
in a research laboratory at a university
and then transferred into a non-profit
entity which is actually funded in some
ways by
hedge funds and other things there's all
kinds of problems there but um
but i i yeah i mean i i think that's the
you know what what you're what you're
getting at is absolutely sort of a
crucial theme of the book which is that
you know all of the
technology doesn't in and of itself
solve all of the hard problems
there are ways in which technology
reveals these problems
um the fact that we can't get broadband
access and we can't get computers to
you know literally millions of the 57
million
school children in america is is
revealing
exacerbating the same time but revealing
new kinds of inequalities as well so i
you know i'm hopeful that uh um
i'm hopeful that the moment leads to
um you know more than anything else sort
of social movements that demand
that we do more for children and their
families in our society
and i hope that we look at them through
these lens of technology but the problem
that skeptics have right now
is that you know like zoom and canvas
are the only games in town zoon and
google classroom the only game
you can't actually critique and resist
them perhaps
if you were to launch a full-throated
critique resistance
you know sort of luddite smashing of
them you'd be like well now we're just
like
mailing paper packets to kids and that's
pretty terrible too
um i mean you know to go back to this
idea it's actually you know
in other writing i've sort of contrasted
skeptics and tinkerers
and uh and charismatics um and
positioned tinkers as a middle way
and i you know there's there's a lot
there's a lot of really good education
technology skepticism that's out there
i think it is challenged in this
particular moment by the fact
that if we want schools to keep
operating in a reasonably functional way
online tools including ones created by
you know monopolistic uh corporations
are going to be pretty central to that
but it does you know i think it's part
of a broader movement in society
of saying we we will not tolerate
we should we should not tolerate these
monopolies operating however they want
to because they're monopolies we should
regulate them
um and in some cases we may really
should be looking at you know
publicly funded alternatives to them
especially for projects that are as
close to
civil society as schools does that get
at some of your issues
yeah absolutely that's that's a great
response thank you
kelly
hi um this is maybe also kind of a big
question but
one thing that i wonder about is how you
teach topics related to
privilege and things like racism to
people that are
have already left formal education and
it seems like one way to reach people is
through technology
but i also kind of dislike the like
instagram size here's how you learn
about racism
and i'm wondering if you have any
thoughts on that or if
the answer is just you have to have
individual conversations with people in
real life
no what what a what a great question to
ask because there's been such a
flourishing
of that you know i think you know there
are a whole bunch of sort of like
white privileged syllabi and you know
you know
google docs and reading clubs and other
kinds of things that have been generated
in various kinds of ways
you know i mean and some of it in in
media that's not explicitly educational
you know the new york times put out a
fabulous podcast
through serial called uh nice white
parents
which is a terrific five episode you
know investigation
of those topics um
and uh you know in
one of my colleagues at mit is a
professor um
named peter senghi at the mit sloan
school management i mean he wrote this
book called the fifth discipline
and he defines really successful
organizations as learning organizations
as organizations in which the process of
getting better at things
[Music]
in do in doing your day-to-day jobs
in performing the function of your firm
you should also be
creating opportunities for all of the
actors in that firm to learn
um these issues of
you know anti-racism bias white
supremacy they're
of keen interest to corporate america
who are generating
all kinds of learning experiences you
know there are probably millions of
americans who in their workplace
um you know are privileged to
participate in or subjected to depending
upon their point of view and the quality
of the these things
sort of learning experiences so i yeah
i'm i'm i'm
quite interested in those kinds of
questions and when you you know and part
of the reason why i stay
in education technology is like i just
don't know
it seems to me that all kinds of media
are going to be central to addressing
that challenge another challenge that
i'm personally really interested in
right now
is uh people don't know how to search
effectively online um and to sort truth
from fiction
um we my colleague sam weinberg at
stanford has done research on lots of
groups
including middle school students and
stanford freshman and tenured historians
who by and large are terrible at um
identifying misinformation and
falsehoods online
and he's also studied this one group of
people fact checkers
at prestigious new or news organizations
who are not only extremely good
at sorting truth from fiction online but
are like quite efficient
and use a series of fairly simple
techniques
um so i'm interested in this question
like you know there's about three
billion people connected to the internet
and we need to teach them all how to do
this um
we need to teach them in schools we need
to teach them in libraries we need to
teach them in their corporations we need
to teach them in senior centers
we need to teach them in civic
organizations like how how are we gonna
when you and when you think about the
question from that scope you're like
well there's gonna be some edtech in
there somewhere
um because that is a that is a huge
you know uh learning goal that we should
have for people in our society
um i mean that that to me is that's the
that's the thing for me that keeps
pulling me sort of away from skepticism
is just this yawning need for learning
felt by billions of people around the
world that it seems like we should be
able to figure out how to use these
tools to address
great i i have a couple of uh questions
in text i did see someone with a hand up
who then put it down
if you do have a question as a panelist
if you put your hand up
use or use the little tool to put your
head the
virtual hand up i'll be able to see you
but in the meantime let me get with
these questions from uh the q a or from
the chat
um one was about uh you mentioned the
technology cannot be expected to work as
a switch and the people need
support for com from a community how do
you envision this kind of community to
take place in an
online environment with moocs have you
seen any platforms today that do a
relatively good job
yeah you know the simplest answer to
that question is that
moocs don't provide that support um
moocs are good for self-paced learning
and they are
and most people are not good at
self-paced learning and the people who
are good at self-paced learning tend to
have had a
formal apprenticeship in the educational
system
um and so if we
want to you know sort of support
community learning we should turn
to other approaches other technology i
think there are neat things that have
been done
incorporating moocs into you know
community-based systems of learning to
have
people take them together in libraries
to have them built into school systems
in different kinds of ways
but but i think also to like
it's important when we see limits to
recognize them
and say like you know don't try to solve
a problem
with a thing that's not going to work
you know i mean maybe keep working maybe
keep doing research and experimenting in
different kinds of ways
um you know in the moocs that we create
um
we try to support people in creating
those community supports and social
learning environments
by encouraging folks to take our courses
in groups to take them in learning
circles but we're not
um because our our learners are
teachers we know that they are embedded
in these social institutions that have
mechanisms for supporting community
learning anyway
you know which is not necessarily the
case for people who want to become
computer scientists or want to become
accountants or data scientists or other
kinds of things like that
so you know it's sort of like having
having healthy
respect for the limits of technology and
saying oh that looks more like a social
problem than a technology problem
another question is do you see technical
innovation
in means of awarding learning credit
grade certificates diplomas
do you see that as having any
significant effect
you know the the place where i think
there's been the most discussion around
this
is around some like badging and micro
credentials and things like that
um that has been an interesting
phenomenon to me because it's a place
where people have been able to generate
supply and demand has not followed
um like people have built it and others
have not come
and it strikes me as a place where
people you know
especially for folks who are trying to
use
some form of micro-credential in a labor
market
just like fundamentally misunderstood
human behavior in the labor market
you know they're saying like what we
want to do is like
give people who are hiring or people who
are admitting people to graduate
programs
like really granular data about people's
abilities
and most people hiring folks do not want
really granular data about people's
um abilities they want like very simple
summaries that allow them to go through
hundreds of resumes at the same time
um and i did and by the time you get to
the sort of two or three candidates that
you really want to go into
you don't want to see a micro credential
or a badge you want to see like
actual evidence of that person's
performance which some micro
credentialing systems have
but you know i think it was an example
of
you know people saying like well here's
something that's possible
and you know if if we could change human
nature then it would allow all these
like really kind of interesting things
to happen you could start sort of
mixing matching you know micro
credentials from different places or
things like that
um and it's not to say that also that
like not
all that innovation there there are
still spaces for innovation but also to
recognize like
there's lots of ways the system has
already done this work i mean mooc
people
have been sort of crowing for a while
about like oh we can create these sort
of like
new micro credentials that are assembled
in different ways this is like a brand
new innovation in higher education
um but in fact like in britain in
i think the end of the 19th century they
developed junior colleges and community
colleges and they invented a degree
called the associate's degree
and that was a kind of micro credential
or a stackable credential that built
into another kind of degree program
you know and in fact like the heavy
lifting of inventing that
happened 110 years ago um and there's
you know the the spaces for innovation
that are left are
sort of fewer and narrower um you know
most of what mooc-based degrees have
done
micromasters and things like that
they've kind of they've created
associate's degrees
but for people who already have degrees
they've created like easier pathways
into master's degrees
but people have master's degrees or for
the most part already affluent already
educated
um so again i mean in the courses that i
teach at mit
especially in undergraduates you know
the main thing that i try to communicate
is that developing effective
technologies requires a rich
understanding of the social technical
systems in which they'll operate
and so many of the false starts in
education technology
are because you have people you know who
are really good at programming and react
or whatever else it is and they don't
understand
complex social technical systems very
well they don't understand
actors in educational systems very well
and so they build things that don't work
very well
um and i mean that's one of the joys of
sort of teaching in
in comparative media studies is just
having people who take these things
very seriously
one more moment for i have one last
question um
from the chat but i wanted to see with
anyone else here
among panelists had a question um and
the question the chat is how could
teachers and students use technology
without being overwhelmed uh
in learning and trying new things it's a
great question
and i like just such a wonderful
question of the moment
because so many people have been thrust
in you know against their will
to these challenges and certainly it is
it has been some of the
sources of deepest frustration i think
particularly for students and families
you know just feeling overwhelmed by all
of the different things they need to
learn to participate in school
and uh you know in normal times you
would say
you know pace yourself yeah i mean we
have all kinds of heuristics that we use
to help people address that challenge we
say things like
um you know if you're a teacher and
you're thinking about incorporating
technology identify a target of
difficulty
identify an area in which you're
teaching something that's really
important to you
that's really hard to teach and where
you think technology might have some
leverage
and through that kind of three-part
rubric most faculty can identify
some part in their curriculum or
syllabus where like oh yeah i'm not
happy at how people learn
these things and i bet there's a way of
doing that better
[Music]
and that you know that's one pathway for
some people that gets them excited about
working on that in a way that feels
manageable
the challenge in pandemic times is you
sort of have to do that for everything
all at once
and you know i mean my my my main piece
of advice there in this moment is just
to
like show yourself and the other people
that you work with a great deal of grace
um there are lots of conflicts that are
happening between
teachers and families between students
and teachers between teachers and school
systems
um and they're because you know we have
as a country have failed to manage the
pandemic
um and and this you know one sad thing
about that is you have like lots of
local actors getting into conflicts
over problems that are created by by
broader social systems
um so you know there's no magic trick to
not getting overwhelmed
pace yourself to the degree that you can
um you know
show yourself and the others around you
some grace um and but then also
recognize
and this is the hopeful piece i keep
going back to um if you can find one of
these
holes where a technology peg fits really
nicely
um it's wonderfully satisfying um and uh
and and builds human capacity in a way
that if you're that if you're patient
and willing to take a sort of
tinkerer's mind frame and be comfortable
with continuous incremental progress
um then uh you know my colleague ken
katinger says that the
step change is just what 20 years of
incremental progress looks like from a
distance
um good if folks are
interested in continuing these
conversations um uh
there's a book club that we're doing a
free virtual book club at 3 p.m
on mondays at failuredisrupt.com
virtualbookclub and would welcome any of
you to drop in
for one session or lots of sessions if
you go to the webpage there's a whole
list of guests and other kinds of things
that are there
if people have other questions you can
find me on twitter at bjfr
or mit and other folks know how to find
me thanks for some
some great questions and thanks to scott
and eric and andrew for hosting
thanks very much justin and thanks
everyone for coming we had a great
turnout
um and we look forward to seeing as many
of you as possible next week when uh
jinguang will be presenting so
thanks thanks everyone again
foreign